hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 5 video
all about Simmons Odyssey her time on
that foreign planet who we still don't
know where it is I'm thinking less and
less that it might be the Thor version
of Hell like a CL hell but there is a
very important reason that they spent so
much time filming on that planet that we
could talk about it spoilers so just
careful if you haven't seen the episode
yet let's get going starting off with
Simmons initial time on the planet just
like WTF how did I get here what the
hell is going on she's got the phone and
she's able to spend almost as much time
as humans can go without food or water
before she has to move on she has to go
find a source of water which she does to
her great relief so it's kind of like
Lawrence of Arabia on another planet I
just say that because she's British
wouldn't she love to have a TARDIS now
she's on the blue planet where's the
blue box she did find the bad man I'm
sure all the pieces are there we did we
could put that together but it's just
the beginning and a series of challenges
that Simmons has to overcome in order to
survive if you're a big fan of the
Odyssey this is like a great allegory
for that story she finds water she
defeats intelligent plant eats said
plant and as we saw later in the episode
the planet isn't completely dead there
used to be life on it there's there's
fungus there's other sources of food on
the number-four though
Simmons versus crazypants mystery person
she gets captured thrown into prison so
we know that there are other people on
the planet and she was running from
something the last time we saw her on
the planet so so we knew something was
chasing her we found out it was the
monster so to speak I guess we could
just call it the monster for now but
it's probably another inhuman but the
reveal is is that it's another person
and he speaks English so eventually she
finds out that it's a NASA astronaut
that in 2001 went through the monolith
on the orders of NASA it was like a NASA
manned mission to learn more about the
other planet we can blame the Bush
administration for green-lighting that
but he explains some of the rules of the
planet to simin this is a terrible place
she wanted to bout the no-fly zone she
learns about the nameless danger that
will take over her mind if she's not
careful will is kind of like this
Robinson Crusoe character you know he
has the skill to survive
he isn't completely crazy but he is
definitely a little bit nutters we've
pretty much given up on being rescued
maybe this is your new home
and of course Simmons who's only been
there for a little while is just like
screw this planet this blows I'm going
home
speaking of which on to number three
meet crazypants we'll probably not a bad
character but also someone we know has
been holding back information so we
can't trust him a hundred percent now
right now we'll just seems like a
character device to help develop Simmons
character I don't know if he's gonna
turn into something bigger she wouldn't
go back to rescue him if he wasn't so I
do think he's joining the cast somewhat
at least for the first half of the
season but he might be like a snack for
the narrative to eat at a later date
like we're just gonna tuck you over away
here and we're gonna eat you later
some big Inhumans gonna come and destroy
you the way wil explains it especially
the danger zone is that people are being
sacrificed to this mystery alien here we
know it's humanoid and its powers affect
the weather on the planet and it may or
may not be responsible for the once
fertile planet turning into this just
barren rock of nothingness so I know my
number two WTF moment mr. e inhuman
alien here very powerful probably not as
evil as we think it is the whole setup
just feels way too obvious for me like
this thing is completely dangerous it
will completely mess with your mind
don't go near it don't learn anything
about it usually the twist in situations
like that we know what a character says
that someone is super dangerous they end
up being just misunderstood they're not
dangerous at all if Simmons was able to
use the Stars to find a way to get back
home to figure out the location and the
timing of the portals she can definitely
learn what this thing is but I don't
think that it's lash I think that it's
something that's also trapped on this
planet I know I talked about the idea
that Andrew might be lashed but wouldn't
it be cool too if lash were some other
character and he were tied to this
phenomenon this other inhuman on this
planet and he was trying to get rid of
Inhumans so that they wouldn't turn into
this crazy inhuman that destroy this
planet now of course we don't know that
he actually destroyed the planet we just
know that we'll thinks that he did if
I'm like oh no my number one WTF moment
Simmons after escaping the planet
convinces Fitz to help her rescue will
that end credits scene
when the Sun comes up was just meant to
be this looks too stark contrast just to
show that will wasn't a hallucination
he's an actual character that was the
thing that he missed most about Earth so
that reminds him about Simmons so he's
hitting like an all-time low the real
question though is is when they go back
to rescue him will that other alien come
back through the portal with them
somehow I feel like they wouldn't tease
this mystery powerful character without
allowing him to come into our world at
some point and the only way to do that
is through those portals but we're still
no closer to finding out what that
planet is but now that we know we can go
back and forth a little bit easier
they'll probably figure it out that'll
probably be Simmons and Fitz's art
figuring out what's going on with this
mystery planet in this mystery figure
here this mystery inhuman just remember
that he in Lash are two different
characters but they might be connected
there might be there might be some
mystery connection that we don't know
about yet let me know that what was your
favorite moment in this episode and what
do you think about them devoting an
entire episode just to Simmons arc I
feel like it was good payoff like for
for her time during the break you know
all the time we didn't see her but
really like there weren't that many
Easter eggs in the episode like it
wasn't very Marvel eat was really just
like a normal-size story there weren't
that many identifiable comic book
moments other than the fact that they're
facing an inhuman here that they don't
know anything about I'm totally cool
with the show doing stuff like this
there been a couple really good Simmons
episodes it's kind of like that episode
in season 2 where it showed her being
part of Hydra she was supposed to
infiltrate Hydra and pretend like she
was one of their lab techs so this was
kind of like an even bigger version of
that just a solo Simmons story great
character work she can be one of the
more interesting characters when they
give her good stories and I feel like
last year when they started to push into
Inhumans she got a little bit racist
like she got very xenophobic about the
Inhumans so I feel like this is a nice
twist on that I did see a little
confusion about the sex scene I saw some
people wondering if Simmons is like
prank pregnant with some some baby now
no I don't think that she's pregnant I
think that their their relationship on
that other planet we're just meant to be
a like a touching moment in time so when
he comes back naturally it's gonna
complicate their little love triangle
they have going on with Fitz but I don't
think it's gonna be that big of a thing
they just meant the show that Simmons
and this other human bonded in their
isolation they just tried to provide
each other with some comfort maybe
they're just like a one-off thing
they're not gonna move in together or
anything whenever he comes back but next
week looks like it's gonna be a good May
episode hopefully we'll find out what's
going on with Andrew because he's mostly
tied to her storylines again there are a
number of possibilities I definitely
don't think that he's dead otherwise jr.
von Strucker wouldn't be crapping his
pants right here I think that either he
is an inhuman himself and manifested
powers and saved himself or another
humans swooped in and helps him out or
he could be like Coulson just be a
normal badass on his own if you remember
one of the earliest marvel short films
they ever did like way back in phase one
was Coulson in the convenience store
taking the out of that robber just
him being badass it was the funniest
thing ever they said when they filmed
that they actually it was so short you
know it wasn't supposed to be this big
deal they weren't supposed to spend a
lot of money but they did such a big
effect sequence like that big fight
seemed with the way the cameras spun
around that they blew their budget so
when they got to the next short film
that they did it was just Coulson and
Sitwell sitting in that diner talking to
each other they're like we can't spend
any money on this we blew the budget on
the last one and as far as I know the
last short film that Marvel did was the
hail to the king one fireman three the
one with with the ten rings in the
Mandarin the real Mandarin so be sure to
subscribe to get next week's video
what's gonna happen tonight is there's a
new episode of arrow I'm trying to catch
up with Supergirl which I think is gonna
be an interesting show this season I
haven't seen anything besides the first
episode and pilots tend to be a little
bit weird compared to the rest of the
series they've learned they've already
filmed several episodes and they've got
a bunch of comic book characters I'm
most interested to learn about Maxwell
Lord on the show they're been versions
of him in the past but I think the CBS
version this Supergirl version is going
to be the most powerful when I should
also say Captain America civil war
trailer the latest Intel is that it's
gonna drop in December near Star Wars
The Force awakens
of course Daisy's gonna use its biggest
film to promote its other biggest film
so while you guys wait for all that
stuff to post you can click here for all
my Captain America Civil War videos and
you can click here for the flash from
last night thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you